merde alors voila tu vois on ferait bien
la dernière
même pas gagné par forfait c'est moi
deux secondes pour trouver un nouveau
partenaire et vous là comment vous vous
appelez mort car je m'appelle mais tout
le monde m'appelle moment vous savez
jouer à la pétanque précieux moments si
difficiles mais non c'est simple s'il y
arrive je me le couple [ __ ] c'est quoi
c'est un monde à l est mais qu'il faut
cracher au bassinet maintenant
ça prend des poses ton est encore la
maman j'espère en gros coup là une
grosse affaire avec la caunette
akouassaga chaque et si pour finir au
rmi comme lui on a rendu leurs enfants
j'y travaille
no comment tu as fait pour emprunter
autant dans ton avis abouti l'argent n'a
pas d'odeur mais quand on n'a pas ça se
sent je dois organiser un concours
international de pétanque et pour le
gagnant je vous propose cinq cent mille
euros
le voilà le gros coup qu'il faut se
présenter titouan bontemps abc l'abruti
a plus envie de devenir un champion je
viens pour les livraisons
merci cela se montre ma mère qui la
prépare après collant avec comme toutes
les mères non la semoule
on est à la pétanque la manger juste
deux trois clans pas en pantacourt que
j'ai des boules de métal donc je suis
obligé de faire du spectacle à l'image
d'arnaud voilà qu'à ce moment là la
caméra m'a vraiment s'amuser à aller
chercher les logos laon bat dans le logo
pour le copain on le voit le logo le
loup attendue étude on le pousse pousse
oui je sais le faire de notre ami et
maghrébin c'est pas une raison pour
l'appeler le couscous
qui est d'accord pour qu'on le prenne
y'en aura des meilleurs capable de
chanter la marseillaise ou dalil et
arabes qu'on se penche sur les biens de
dubaï n'a pas un petit rapport l'arabe
dubaï dubai arabe
vous le prenez et d'intégrer juste
savoir si vous alliez vous comportez
comme pendant toute la tournée ou six
avaient des chances de saint honoré
momoa nom qui pète un nom qui claque de
bois - il ya non c'est sur wii on
vérifiera quoi la gloire n'est plus là
pour ça j'ai changé pas trop escale à la
starlette lui faut des journalistes et
du sable on montre aux jo bull
pièce c'est moctar new delhi c'est le
capitaine de l'équipe carles amis c'est
le meilleur choix sa génération
maghrébine
il est madame boutin ah oui n'obtient
boudali et maghrébins comme tout le
monde quoi et si demain il me venait
l'idée saugrenue d'apprendre la pétanque
je prendrai pour professeur un français
de souche aller les mains sur michael
mais j'ai rien vu depuis toujours en
séjour irrégulier bonbons 120 ça vaut
mieux pour tout le monde sait comment la
tuerie agir ici si tu aimes ip connaît
ni baisers ni sortir le soir c'est super
juste derrière c'est plus mon problème
on sent chez vous un vrai sens profonde
amitié
hélas
vous avez mokhtar ch tout le monde m'a
tellement
là
oui
à
non mais je crois que vous êtes trompé
de fil c'est de l'autre côté là je
voudrais être algérien